[Music]
in organized thief news oh you said that
right way yes like directing mixer I'm
sitting there submitted by for real for
you know what I'm just [ __ ] up okay
police made the final entry entry and a
thieves journal journal I don't know
like right now their crime is [ __ ] and
then they get caught in the cops head
and his life ended here oh yes yeah see
I knew it oh I should write these that
article is that thieves even have a
journal like today I robbed the house
and it made me feel so good in the
position that Joe loves honest tummy
with his feet up yeah today today I
killed a man
yeah the poster of one of the [ __ ]
Jonas Brothers and today I wasn't
feeling my best so I decided not to go
and rob yeah that's pretty much it man
you nailed it I'm good at this you know
beep he was doing alcohol he kept a very
detailed list
he's got inventory yeah I like the step
and then the dates and everything they
did he even worked on Christmas but then
you put a day off on these three days
Wow I've been working so hard lately
listing Monday February 6th empty until
the cops Photoshop arrested
muah-ha-ha-ha-ha wow that's got arrested
deserved it wait so he was stealing like
just like drinks at a bar or no he was
stealing from a Costco from liquor
stores Oh like I'm gonna come in
gunpoint and be like what's up none well
then in specific exact give me a gallon
of Kahlua
it's just that are you could've been
doing one of these things I feel like it
was more that so it's a shoplifter yeah
but what's the purpose like just to get
drunk are you gonna resell that let go a
lot so you got two right if you reach
under I don't know
he's trying to make this guy out to be
the devil yeah he's underage he Freddie
got portal of pornography going on why
would you send it to resell to make
moola oh like it's free I got it which
is like how much money can you get from
here anyway right like you got a bottle
of tequila or yeah that's always in the
back yeah
the first day he sold five bottles of
Jose Cuervo and two bottles of Grey
Goose what's Cuervo 21 at all that about
140 hundred or tea that's how much you
made in a day yeah you make 140 day
that's not too bad that's very good do
some math 365 you probably make a six
figure in his thing in the thing that he
wrote was about a thousand dollars it's
not six figures what's a hundred days
maybe a thousand Dave Oh his shopping
list was about two thousand dollars
worth the alcohol like I knew that yeah
yeah a thousand a day will be three
three three meme that has all the
[ __ ] wait thousand a day for a month
will be thirty thousand if it's
yesterday mine so you make you make
about two hundred today yes good money
that's like six thousand a seventy two
thousand seventy three thousand a year
damn you're really good at math 72 no
yeah sixty-five yeah Oh dad leap year
leap year maybe makes a little less
after taxes after his beef taxes maybe
he takes home 60 K because he pays his
taxes the Godfather he's there
responsible what kind of robber are you
I'm uh I had to pay my texts have a good
work I'm a good one
he still has morals I don't think I'm
robbing a liquor store if I'm robbing
nothing you know what are you robbing
nothing because I'm a good citizen that
pays my taxes but if I could steal
something I would take a penny from
every citizen in the u.s. that's called
office space you seen that movie yeah
office actual crime that they did that
what do they do
digitally they'll take like less than a
penny off of every transaction that's
happening and so it Noah it doesn't go
notice and I don't know if this is even
possible I'm not [ __ ] Morpheus or
something but hypothetically you know it
happen
and they get heat at that person I
forgot coming break a quarter a quarter
of a penny off of every transaction or
every bank account or every human or
every subscriber send it to my venmo
and basically you just [ __ ] become
rich really quick Wow yeah interesting
impressed by my calculations Girl Talk
we were impressed
they don't give G Oh said we needed mean
with all the numbers that's all I see
you around you right now anyway yes so
police just posted that that photo I
showed you guys on their Facebook page
and they just thought it was really
funny I think it's pretty funny
how did you that's wrong because why are
you journaling that yeah that was an
irony would be he's trying to keep track
of his record I was gonna say if he is a
cycle math guy and he's trying to keep
track like we just kind of joked about
how much money you're making I get it
but uh he's such a responsible tracking
his progress he's lucky four bottles
today yeah bottles tomorrow I write
everything down really I don't really do
everything I need to know I had an
accounting book when I was drug-dealing
oh yeah I was writing down notes and
then like who bought what who owes me I
had a I had a page of like cents someone
owed how organized you know I wanted to
make make sure that it was profiting you
know I'm not breaking even and then I
even counted like how much gas I spent
on delivering [ __ ] don't they say like
all like serial killers or a high
percentage of them how about some kind
of trophy yeah yeah I'm kind of like
thing that they have like it'll keep the
panties of every girl that's what I mean
yeah textures what pops in my mind when
he cuz he's like super intelligent when
he goes around these things and so like
keeping notes kind of makes sense yes
man was a forty years old so that kind
of fall out of picture a little bit more
he's more responsible is what you're
saying because he's older he was
tracking his finances
yeah that makes sense I would do that I
would even yeah because you want to know
how much is coming in how much it's
going now I mean no one is good going
now
but yeah basic books we do that with our
training why wouldn't we do it if we
were like with our income I've never
even done it with my training
you've never done it with your training
liar code no you don't you might do it
mentally basically I'm really good so
every single
you know you're adding way or adding a
restoration an oh guy for anything all
right programs down for other people
they obviously have to know what I'm
doing I don't know it's [ __ ] maybe
that's all y'all suffer got stronger
tears my kind of injury that's why he's
been doing the same level like with
Anthony you and you're like we gonna win
that was the [ __ ] ringer right there
that's how you know you're close to boy
yeah yeah yeah yeah when he makes you
feel like [ __ ] yep
I feel great over here Mike never coming
back my notes got notes I write so much
notes I did - yeah and it sometimes I go
back and I'm like well what does this
mean and I'm spending like an hour
trying to figure it out and I'm like oh
by freaking fish for like that's like I
do phone knows I do phone notes cuz I
hate my writing yeah cuz then I get
impatient cuz I want to write faster so
then my hands like cramps up fever more
my writing gets even worse that's why I
bad that cursive is not being taught
anymore cuz that's the easiest we write
of curses yep
oh that's so cute you don't you know I
write in cursive I do too but I was
taught like in the first grade in the
never again
Oh like I think I was in that transition
point so I know it but I never used it
so much I write in cursive I get like
sentimental you want to hear more weird
[ __ ] about my school every essay you
wrote you didn't turn it into his
handwritten bro remember when people
used to have to write things out yeah it
was in that generation bro yeah me too
is that the fight plagiarism it's - so
even if you were to plagiarize you would
have to copy out their hand yeah I think
that's probably like 1% of it it's to
feel that you're writing more and feel
more connected to the words and feel
more connected to your work you'd also
have to write a [ __ ] hippie like yeah
and you'd have to art artwork the border
so it's not just like a [ __ ] square
like you draw it fine that's how I
started all of my essays was just
drawing [ __ ] like every [ __ ]
presentation I do I started with the
font first I had to pick all that first
year and then
was I all right I got right now oh yeah
I would take forever
picking the font that I know why do you
spend so much time doing non-project
things and I think like when teachers
told me to do something even if I wanted
to do it I didn't do it yeah Anthony
because they told you yeah because it
became work so then it's like this
sounds fun but then how would they have
been able to get you to do it that's
probably why I didn't do so that's what
you say like Joe I don't want you to
write this essay I spent a lot of time
doing like projects on my own that I
created like like I don't know like I
would get a magazine and I would just
like draw what was in there or whatever
yeah yeah but I wouldn't do the school I
think that's human nature even as adults
really I think so I think that's just us
maybe like look at what we do for work
maybe you know what I mean it's not very
typical well no cuz when I worked I I
think I did good work right like you you
got to express and do so many projects
well because they carried in front of
you was money and if you don't have this
money then you can't survive yes because
the teachers like you go to school you
don't get paid to do that [ __ ] right and
that's like I don't care about grades
right so what I get out of it yeah but
it's stupid because I could have been
smarter way faster but I also feel like
you need school for the first 18 years
cuz what else oh you're gonna be doing
it as a kid you know and we're gonna
feel functional then what are the
Mexicans gonna do taking all these
little white kids jobs yeah my uni and I
even encouraged some college just
because they gives you like a different
perspective you don't have to like
finish and graduate I just gave my
brother this advice you have to finish
in graduate but I think the interactions
you have are very much like this where
you have different while adults yeah and
everybody gets to say what they think
and nobody's gets aggressive you know
and you don't really get to do that
outside of college well in college
people from different parts of the world
come together
yeah whereas just your your high school
it's literally just the district
neighbor part of that zip code then you
don't and typically it like sub coats
are like surrounded by the same kind of
people yeah yeah yeah
yeah like it's like mainly Asian or
mainly like or whatever that's fun
around diverse thinking yeah schools fun
high school I hated it but college was
fun
college isn't even that diverse in
thinking anymore depends you don't think
for sure depends I went a couple I don't
think so I think it's it's been pretty
one one-sided you know like you're not
gonna go into college and have people
that are like anti-gay everyone's cool
with gay Oh in college yeah yeah I think
the business oh yes you going to we
might head to the south or something a
little bit more Ivy League and things
but I think that's the cool thing of it
you can go as anything that's not
hurting anyone else and people will hear
you out of me like alright that's
different you know yeah a little more
food yeah yeah yeah
[Music]